18 mars 1962 après sept ans et demi de
guerre qui ne dit pas son nom est
presque un an de négociations la france
et l'algérie signent les accords d'evian
belkacem krim et la délégation et pellen
louis joxe et la délégation française se
sont encore une fois retrouvée mais
cette fois pour conclure et le soir même
à les viser le général de gaulle pouvait
annoncer aux foules française la
conclusion du effet le feu en algérie à
cessez-le-feu appliquée dès le lendemain
le 19 mars 1962
loin de réjouir tous les belligérants on
commence plus facilement d'une guerre
qu'on l'a finie et celle d'algérie ne
mentent pas à la règle l'opération ils
ont volé mes jambes sont venus
manifester avec
la passion ne voulons pas face à
me comprendre avec nos séances
d'hésitations et les pieds noirs aussi
sera va faire une balade qu'est-ce qui
vous tracasse le plus c'est le fait de
ne plus avoir de boulot ou le fait que
peut-être vous risquez d'être embêté
après parce que vous avez été dans
l'armée française les deux
après le cessez le feu et les référents
byrne des deux côtés de la méditerranée
en faveur de l'indépendance les
attentats continuent les enlèvements les
européens d'algérie parle de choix entre
la valise ou le cercueil d'heure du
meurtre peur d'un enlèvement peur d'une
balle perdue peur de tout
ils étaient ce jour-là 15 cents ou 2000
femmes enfants vieillards qui s'embarque
est pour la métropole ce cessez le feu
apparaît comme une trahison pour les
français d'algérie les années passent et
le ressentiment est toujours là à tel
point qu'il est plus que délicat de
trouver une date pour commémorer la fin
de la guerre d'algérie le premier à
choisir le 19 mars c'est françois
hollande en 2016 et les réactions ne se
font pas attendre la france nous a
laissé tomber
on a perdu tout ce que nos grands pères
rentrée et arrière-grand-père et
commémorer cette date c'est pas bon non
non ce matin dans le figaro nicolas
sarkozy dénonce lui aussi le choix du
chef de l'état
pour qu'une commémoration soit commune
il faut que la date célébrée soit
acceptée par tous or le 19 mars reste au
coeur d'un débat douloureux
une date qui cristallise les tensions à
tel point que certains voudraient la
voir disparaître
à l'image de robert ménard maire de
béziers ici j la rue du 19 mars 1962
robert ménard lui a donné le nom d'un
partisan de l'algérie française des
milliers de français d'algérie des
jeunes du contingent des dizaines de
milliers de harkis sont morts après
cette date une polémique relancée cet
hiver quand emmanuel macron annoncé
vouloir commémorer les 60 ans des
accords d'evian
[Musique]